[Music]
and don't believe the hype news
don't do it submitted by I farted
psychologists want you to know that the
myers-briggs personality test is
[ __ ] is [ __ ] you ready that like
the ENTJ I am or whatever oh I thought
that was the one where you come in a
napkin what do you see oh yeah Rorschach
Rorschach's okay I thought it was that
that's a fortune teller
dubby don't if you go to a psychologist
office and they're like alright hold on
you know they're like ok what's your
number four one two three four okay open
it up okay do you like blue all right
all the girl used to make that what was
the other one hash or Shaq or some mash
- oh that one that one [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] you know what I always felt left
off on you know when girls do the
[ __ ] Chinese jump rope or whatever no
Chinese jump rope is the other one
cradle right yeah baby they do that and
then the girl takes takes the thing and
does another thing and gives it back I'm
just like spider waves go like and then
they'll pinch it a certain way they love
it let me try that [ __ ] I know I've been
trying to find that the colorful rope
the Chinese jump rope thing I've been
wanting you wait
Chinese jump rope as long as you wear it
and your ankles okay cool dude I was a
[ __ ] master at that [ __ ] but I would
have to jump I don't know what that is
what that one's fun it's like yeah
there's two people standing and then
there's like a like uh looks like a
rubber band
oh and then you loop it
in your legs yeah could we believe our
dick your party we should play the old
elementary school game just [ __ ] sit
there with a little thing that you may
want to do evil we're doing it we're
doing it what about the Chinese finger
trap just like okay I was dumb cuz I
didn't know when I was really little and
the more you stuck I never got before
okay so anyways Myers Brigg good so if
you guys don't know what it is it's an
introspective self-reported
questionnaire designed to indicate how
people perceive the world based on his
spectrum which involves sixteen
personality types so it was first
published in 1943 by Katherine Briggs
and her daughter Isabel Myers mares nice
Myers Myers you did Tim Myers Briggs I
know I'm done Myers okay so they were
not psychologists but they did study the
works of Carl Jung Yong Yong thank you I
know it is spelt at the Jayla so Carl
Jung
he was a Swiss psychiatrist and
psychoanalyst I think he was the father
of cognitive behavioral theory they're
saying that some psychologists they
don't really value Karl's research
because he wasn't actually a researcher
she just made up [ __ ]
his theory should not be considered Saul
this is what their thing he was like hmm
okay and then that's how he came up with
his ideas oh so many people right now
because it's like in psychology there's
different schools of thought so people
either use this technique and cognitive
theory or they Freud's outdated but he's
very popular where he believes that
everyone's trying to [ __ ] their mama and
their papa yeah and then there's just
all these different I guess thoughts of
psychology and different methods and
they all kind of clash it's very
interesting
it doesn't really fall under one thing
yeah like you have hardcore more on the
neuroscience just straight-up math and
science kind of guys that just believe
everything is heart and soul and the
dissing of that right I mean super hard
science and then there's the other side
of psychology that's kind of like
witchcraft like it's it's I mean it's
beyond psychology it's just like I
thought it was Beyonce
it's like alternative medicine and [ __ ]
like it's not even science anymore you
know it's just like magic
I think the feelings it's like some
hippy [ __ ] yeah it's really weird you're
depressed yeah they're saying that this
myers-briggs test was designed to
categorize people with questions based
on Jung's interpretation of the four
core psychological functions which is
extroversion versus introversion
intuitive versus sensing feeling versus
thinking and judging versus perceiving
and so after you complete this
questionnaire then you get a four letter
barcode and for example I and SJ and
then it corresponds to which category
you fall into so that's how the test
works so now they're saying that this
test has evolved into common pop
psychology and so some businesses even
use this test to determine hiring
decisions and there there are academic
papers published evaluating the
correlation between this test and
employment satisfaction and then there's
there's a ton of personality type
meetups on the internet and so it's a
common theme and all of this is leading
up to a big but but it's like a [ __ ]
but psychologists want you to know that
they believe this test is no more
predictive than a Chinese fortune cookie
that there is no evidence behind the
test and it carries no predictive power
whatsoever and there is no obvious
evidence that there are sixteen unique
categories in which people can be
pleased there's way more than that and I
think it's like horoscopes
I'm an Aries so you know I'm a fire sign
and I'm firing care come on man you
telling me everybody in my month has a
[ __ ] hot temper
yeah that's not true I got a [ __ ]
temper she does it yeah so but we're
both Aries so psychologists call us the
Barnum effect so the Barnum effect says
that if you write something that's so
general it can apply to anyone and that
and they all sound right yeah and
they're also positive and kind of
generic and so people just go like oh my
god is a miracle this is me like this is
totally applies to me and it's always
like abyss or that like it's like do you
like to stay at home or do you like to
go outside and it's like the [ __ ] do I
like to do both of them do you like big
crowds or do you like small crowds you
know or like no crowds
I'd like the main complaint I take it
with a grain of salt man you can't let
categories identify who you are but
humans are like sponges to it if you
tell someone that they are something
they believe it they become that you
know if a human being agrees with what
you tell them so some people they're
very weak to negative thinking because
if you constantly surrounded by negative
thinking and their mind tends to agree
with everything they hear and if they
don't have a strong sense of self then
they start become they start believing
those negative thoughts but it all comes
from being a child and you know your
parents is saying you know don't you
know you you don't know how to dance or
something like maybe one day you're
dancing too much and your parents are
annoyed cuz they are stressed out from
work and they say some shitty [ __ ] like
like you don't know how to dance stop
dancing right and from that day on you
believe you can't dance anymore
and you're now a 40 year old woman that
shy she doesn't want to dance like when
everyone's dancing at the wedding or
whatever
that's how personalities are really
developed is like we soak up what people
say to us and we agree or disagree with
that and so these characteristics like
some people might read that and go oh
yeah you know what I do like parties
because all they're thinking about is
like I've been to that party the other
day I had a great experience maybe I'm
an extrovert but in reality there are
shy people like
does it make sense is there anything
that you feel I can really make a test
of some sort there is no none right I
think there's too many unique
experiences like for example like if two
people get the same four letters and one
person has been raped before you're
gonna say that this person's personality
is like exactly the same as this person
you know at this I think people are made
up of all the experiences that they've
been through and each person has very
very unique experiences that make up who
they are in its room I think it's just -
it's impossible to generalize the entire
world into 16 categories and what is the
real point of knowing these things I
mean a lot of people they also they they
need to find their identity so I think
people are just searching for that so
some people are like whether they go
through the horoscope so they go through
this should they go through that they
just want to figure out like oh this is
who I am and really it it's just easier
to just grasp something that's general
really rather than really trying to
figure out who they are yeah I think
people always need to know
I mean why think we're all like that we
just need to know and that's how egos
built and all that stuff but I think
what I personally think is that people
are very fluid like you're not the same
person you were 10 years ago five years
ago you might be a party animal in high
school and love to be out all the time
but when you're 30 you might want to be
home all day and not want to go out
anymore and be a little bit more shy
like I think there's no like one thing
you know I mean like but certain things
I think I do like about how they explain
extrovert and introvert like how
extroverts go out and you get energy
from other people's energy introverts
are kind of overwhelmed with too much
people's energy and it's just I know
that this exists but without anything
really identifying and backing that kind
of research I think it's it could be
like horoscopes where people just they
rely on it so much that they lose
confidence in their own BOTS yeah I mean
like by taking this 16 personality test
you guys think you would have a better
understanding of how to communicate to
that person hmm maybe I mean I guess
anything helps but yeah it's one of
those things where like I don't
know how every person is gonna deal with
the results you know so recently I did a
23andme right yeah and there's this
section of muscle fibers so there's
three different muscle groups two is a
fast twitch muscle and one is a slow
twitch muscle and the way that it's
written on 23andme it says power
athletes you are unlikely to be a power
athlete and they describe it right but
if I wasn't informed about just the way
the the physio like body work I would
assume that oh that means I'm unathletic
but because I don't have the muscle
fiber but they also did explain that you
know someone could have the gene for for
the power athlete gene but this person
could be five feet with short legs you
know what I mean so there's there's so
many variables but a lot of people they
take these things and then they soak it
in and then it becomes who they are and
then there's no real sense and
confidence of like Who I am you know
people could change whatever they are
that's what I believe sure yeah these
are like people that are new life
coaches all I knew is a fortune cookie
I'm good hey guys if you guys didn't
know we have a social media account on
Instagram call it the JK film so you
guys should better follow it because we
post up clips pictures we got some
instant stories going on so go ahead and
fall it right now the next video click
up here
[Music]